I'm a school counselor I love how you're
always positive about everything but I
feel like I'm the same way but I feel
like after a while you're looked at that
person to always be positive it's a lot
of pressure so like how do you de-stress
the New York Jets help me a lot it's
like they probably will ironically them
being bad helps me like yelling at the
TV you get your frustration out in other
places honestly perspective being
grateful that I'm the person that people
rely on for positivity is much better
than being the other person I just feel
like
other people you gotta humble yourself
one of the ways that I take pressure off
of me not failing in front of others is
reminding people in my circles that I'm
human and I make mistakes which took me
some time you see all these people just
complaining about the little stuff
shifting their perspective and just
teaching them like through your own
actions you can only put in the Reps
yeah as a middle school counselor it's
just hard because those kids are like oh
my friend's not talking with me oh and
it's the end of the world you know and
that's when mental health comes in so of
course it's cool to have that job though
to be that influence on those kids
that's what this is for me yeah it's 100